yeah i would say that protests erupted
in dc this week over the
officer-involved shooting of a black man
but that would be
the wrong way to put it protests could
not erupt because they were already
happening cities across the country have
been in a state of perpetual protest for
weeks and months now
new events are simply tossed like more
logs into the fire protests are not
protests are not really in response to
the events it is more that the events
are fabricated to feed the protest
so this time word was spread on social
media that a
quote child had been shot quote in the
back by police
blm activists took to the streets
ranting and raving about the
cold-blooded execution of an innocent
kid
witnesses on the ground well not not
witnesses of the event but witnesses to
other alleged witnesses who supposedly
saw it or heard about it or
heard from someone who talked to someone
who saw it
they said that the quote child was also
quote unarmed
so here's one such witness thrice
removed reporting
what she saw or rather what she heard
about
from other people who supposedly saw it
listen to this
i'm actually servicing a group of
students and we heard
shots fired and we came over to see
uh different police and we found out a
17 year old was shot
by the police officer and do we have any
details
um from the community on on what
happened
um one thing is the young man with
unarmed
that's one detail and the everyone is
just heartbroken right now
and in disbelief that a police officer
would take a young man's life
i some people were saying he was shot in
the back is that something can be
verified or is it too early to say
um i guess it's too early just too early
to say um because there's been some
things where he was sat in the back and
then you've also heard that he reciting
his chest
so it's too early to say yes the one
thing we know for sure
is that he was unarmed that's the one
detail we know that's the one thing we
can say for sure based on the
unassailable testimony of some random
people on the street who i just talked
to 12 seconds ago
but as we are of course stuck here in
this eternal time loop like groundhog
day but with
more racial strife and less bill murray
the next part of the story unfolded
you know exactly as expected almost
everything we heard from the activists
and supposed witnesses was false d.c
police held a press conference on
thursday released the body cam footage
of the officer who filed the fatal shot
in fact let's go to the press conference
here's the police chief describing
what actually happened yesterday at
about
3 49 p.m uniformed
members of the 7th district were in the
area of the 200 block of orange street
southeast to investigate the report
of a man in possession of a gun
officers had seen a live stream of video
on social media of the man with the gun
and knew him from previous contacts as
officers
exited their patrol car to approach a
parked car that was occupied
by multiple men two individuals fled on
foot
and officers pursued them one of those
men brandished a firearm from his
waistband as he was fleeing
in response an mpd officer just
discharged his service weapon
firing a single shot at the individual
the individual sustained a single
gunshot wound to the to his chest
officers initiated first aid to the man
and members of the d.c
fire and ems transported him to a local
hospital where he was pronounced dead
the decedent has been identified as 18
year old dion
kay of southeast dc officers did
recover a firearm that mr we believe
that mr k
was in possession of at the time of the
incident in fact he actually understates
the case there
the body cam clearly shows that the
suspect dionne k 18 years old by the way
not a child
is running towards the officer with his
gun drawn
let's take a look at that body cam
footage right now
don't move
[Music]
i don't know i'm looking for the gun
he's up there
i did
[Music]
so he was not unarmed he was not shot in
the back
he has been been spotted earlier in the
day driving around town brandishing his
guns
uh kaye had shot a live stream video of
himself and his friends waving their
guns around
we're told that officers recognize kay
knew him to be as they put it a quote
validated gang member but none of this
matters
in our post-truth society those who
claim that kay was an unarmed innocent
child
shot in the back by white supremacist
only to find out that kaye was actually
an armed adult gang member
shot in the chest by a hispanic officer
while brandishing his weapon
simply ignored the new revelations or
else seamlessly transitioned into a
new story about a remorseful suspect who
was just about to throw his gun away
before callous officers shot him dead
little effort is made anymore to come up
with a plausible narrative
you know we've reached a point where the
facts simply
do not matter period this was evidenced
elsewhere this week when protests began
again the word began is used loosely
here
in rochester over the death of daniel
prude
now he died several months ago after
asphyxiating with a hood over his head
while in police custody prude was in
custody because he was
running naked through the streets at
three o'clock in the morning while high
on pcp
the hood was placed over his head
because he was spitting on the arresting
officers after telling them
that he had coveted remember this was
also in march in the in the early days
of the covet hysteria
um the medical examiner report lists
delirium and pcp intoxication as
contributing factors in his death once
again though
facts don't matter what matters is how
people feel
well certain people anyway it doesn't
matter how the police officers feel
doesn't matter how business owners and
residents feel when their livelihoods
are destroyed by looters and rioters
npr just published an interview with
vicky osterweil
who's the author of a book called in
defense of looting
one of the descent defenses she offered
for the looting in the interview not
making this up
is that looting feels good she says
direct quote
it provides people with an imaginative
imaginative sense of freedom and
pleasure
it helps them imagine a world that could
be and
i think that's part of part of it that
doesn't really get talked about that
riots eluding are experienced as sort of
joyous and liberatory yes it isn't
talked about because it's insane
vicky you psychopath so the people
victimized by looting their feelings
don't matter
um that doesn't matter it also doesn't
matter how the past
victims of lionized criminals like
george floyd feel or jacob or jacob
blake
how their victims feel when they see
their tormentors and abusers hailed as
civil rights martyrs
as it turns out feelings matter about as
much as facts
all that really counts is the far left
ideological agenda
feelings and facts are weighted
according to their usefulness to that
agenda
and i actually think this is an
important point to emphasize because
if somebody valued feelings over facts
they'd be wrong and irrational but if
they used that scale consistently and
applied it to everyone we'd have to at
least admit that they're empathetic
which is a positive trait empathetic to
the point of madness i grant you but
empathetic nonetheless yet when you look
at blm militants or writers or looters
do you see empathy do you see any great
concern
for the feelings of others when you look
at antifa is that what you see no
they are not only dismissive of facts
but also dismissive of the impact their
actions have on others
if they care about feelings at all it is
only their own feelings
nobody else's now in a world where
meaningful reflection is possible it
would be worthwhile
to step up to the side here and consider
why events
like the dion case shooting actually
happen so pretending for a moment that
we live in such a world let me suggest
that
these events have very little to do with
police officers
all of the police reform in the world
won't stop men like dion kay for getting
themselves hurt or killed
if not by police than by somebody else
amid the the panic over police police
shootings and the never-ending
dissection
and second guessing of the actions of
police officers rarely
does anyone stop to ask questions about
the suspect
that's too bad because several very good
questions could be asked
speaking specifically of dion k those
similar questions arise in many of these
situations
we might ask why was he running riding
around town waving his gun around
why did he advertise his crimes on a
public forum for all to see
why did he run when the police arrived
why did he draw his gun
if he had made different choices
anywhere along that chain
he'd still be alive today if the police
did anything wrong
which they didn't it would be in their
reaction to the bad
choices of dion k with extremely rare
exception this is
almost always the case in police
shootings
even the bad ones are in nearly every
case
a bad reaction to a bad choice by the
other guy
yet we're never supposed to question
those choices the first choices the
other guy's choices
we're supposed to start our
investigation further down the line
this is why it's always concluded that
officers are horrible sociopathic
murderers because
we assess their reaction independent of
the thing they're reacting to which is
like
if i'm driving recklessly and i swerve
on into oncoming traffic
and you happen to be in the oncoming
traffic and so you swerve too and kill
someone
but the accident investigators
completely ignore my role in it
that'd be great for me but you're
screwed because now it will
automatically look like you were drunk
or reckless
when really the drunken reckless person
was me and even if you were drunk and
reckless making the whole thing much
worse than it had to be
it still wouldn't be fair to arbitrarily
absolve me of all blame and act like i
had nothing to do with it
and it's even more important in cases
like this to try and uncover the reasons
behind dionne case behavior because
there are a lot of dion k's in dc
and every other major city in america
there is if you like a systemic
problem an underlying problem
but it has nothing to do with the police
and the symptoms of this problem are
well known crime violence murder drugs
all these things that plague these
communities
that's why the police are more involved
you know in these communities and more
interactive
and why police and and why police
interactions are more likely to turn
violent
only a vanishingly small percentage of
arrests turn deadly but the more crime
you have in a community
the more arrests the more people killed
by cops
it's a very simple formula really it's
not confusing
so again the conversation must go back
to the crime why is the crime happening
if you have an 18 year old guy running
around town brandishing gums a lot
live streaming it on instagram
pretending like real life is a rap video
that he draws his gun on police and gets
shot
it is just the height of absurdity to
suggest that the problem is the police
and not the culture and upbringing that
led him to make those choices
now i don't know dion case specific
family situation i think i could make a
pretty educated guess but
what i can say is that for many guys
like dion k
they grow up without fathers in the home
they are missing a strong
male role model someone to show them
what to do
with all of that masculine energy and an
aggressiveness
someone to direct them towards healthy
outlets for the innate need they have to
be seen as tough
and strong and intimidating a desire
that all boys have a desire that should
not be suppressed
but rather directed if it's not directed
or perhaps harnessed as a better word
that's when very bad things happen
so in these crime-ridden communities in
the city
if a boy has no male role model no one
to direct
and harness his masculine energy he will
end up looking in two places for that
direction
one to his peers who are just as lost as
he is
and two to the media pop culture
especially rap music in those instagram
videos dion k
is literally acting out rap music while
listening to it
he is imitating it in real time
and that's unfortunate because the music
explicitly glorifies drugs violence and
criminality
what happens then when a kid with no
father
no male role model pumps those kinds of
messages
into his ears all day every day all
throughout his formative years
and lives in an environment that in all
the wrong ways
mirrors those same messages well we see
what happens
baltimore happens chicago happens dc
happens
but we aren't supposed to talk about the
culture the upbringing or lack thereof
no
no when a kid has a no father figure no
male role models
and his mind his mind spends all of its
formative years marinating
in in messaging that expressly glorify
suicidal criminal behavior and then he
actually goes and commits suicidal
criminal behavior the issue is the
police
somehow just the police it's not a
problem of culture it's not a problem a
bad upbringing
it's not a problem of bad choices
nothing and no one else is to blame
but the police a man can make a hundred
bad choices in a day all leading to the
final bad choice of drawing a gun on a
cop
and somehow the cop is to blame for
everything all of it the whole chain of
events
nobody else nothing else nothing else to
see here folks just the police
that's the only thing to talk about
right
no no that's not the only thing to talk
about
there's a lot more to talk about and i
think it's time we start
talking about it hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated